9 hectares dans les côtes de beaune et
l'amour de la vigne en héritage à 30 ans
sarah a repris les rênes du domaine
familial avec son frère on connaît ça
depuis qu'on est tout petit donc on
n'arrive pas sans savoir de quoi on va
parler et mercor on va se tourner donc
on sait déjà dans quoi on s'engage et
après il ya toujours des choses à
apprendre au fur et à mesure et même au
bout d'un an et demi j'apprends toujours
des choses quasiment tous les jours la
côte d'or compte aujourd'hui 1200
exploitations comme celles que codirige
sahara et ces domaines sont les premiers
employeurs de la filière avec deux mille
six cent cinquante salariés permanents
sans compter les saisonniers pendant la
période des vendanges des emplois
directs mais il y à tous les autres il
suffit de rejoindre guillaume le frère
de sarah dans leur toute nouvelle
cuverie pour s'en rendre compte que ce
soit les cuves le matériel mécanique les
flux tout ce qu'on utilise assez du
local et c'est que ça fait quand même
trahi énormément puisqu'après même
derrière en aval bouteilles bouchons
capsules étiquette carton tout ça fait
travailler dans la viticulture fait
travailler eric milliard par exemple
tonnelier depuis plus de 30 ans dans une
grande entreprise du secteur
il s'est installé à son compte en
juillet dernier un métier où fait
passionnés fois on vit pas avoir peur du
bruit pas avoir peur de travailler mais
c'est un métier qui donne plein de
bonnes choses quand on fabrique un fût
quand on se retourne le soir on a on a
vraiment fait quelque chose de ses mains
et c'est vraiment une vraie valeur sans
surprise c'est au tour de bonnes que se
concentre la plupart des emplois de la
filière dans la capitale des vins de
bourgogne 22 % des salariés occupent un
poste lié à la production viticole plus
d'un sur cinq parmi les plus gros
employeurs les grandes maisons qui font
déjà travaillé 2500 personnes
elle aimerait en recruter davantage dans
des postes très variés mais peine à
trouver des candidats
le cas de frédéric drouet le président
du négoce bourguignon la difficulté de
notre métier aujourd'hui c'est de
trouver les compétences
malheureusement on n'a pas expliqué
assez en amont auprès des jeunes qui
arrivaient sur le marché du travail
le côté noble de tous nos métiers on ne
cherche pas que des commerciaux on
cherche également un caviste un
tractoriste quelqu'un qui puisse
maintenir entretenir une machine qui
étiquette qui embouteille le vin étrange
paradoxe d'une filière emblématique de
l'économie côte-d'orienne ses vins font
rêver la planète entière
mais elles risquent bientôt de manquer
de bras pour les produire ou les vendre